because usually people from La they give
you faux respect they give you like
they've heard your name
so then they act like they know anything
about you if I were in La I would be
doing that let me show you what I would
do if you came out of like yeah give Dan
dude I've been wanting to have
you on forever man how you been that's
good
you good can I give you what I would be
like in LA yes I'd go is this your
podcast or mine is your podcast right
and I'm I'm a guest on your podcast it
would be a lot of this thank you yeah
thank you for having me eyebrows up
thank you yeah this is
so great to be here I have been such a
fan of yours thank you oh I appreciate
that I appreciate it I appreciate that
this is like dueling